Let's discuss the machine
learning based approaches.
Machine learning approaches can
automatically build a model
using the labeled normal training data.
That is, a machine learning algorithm
fixes input examples of normal data and
outputs a model.
That is then able to classify
subsequently observed data
as either normal or anormalous.
Machine learning base models can
automatically handle small changes or
variations in the observed data.
It can also capture
the inter-dependencies or
the deeper connections between
the measures of the observed data.
On the other hand for these approaches
to be effective the normal training data
must be representative of
normal behaviors otherwise
when we apply the model to detection
there could be a lot of false positives.
In addition in the training phase
it required a lot of data and
a lot of of power.
However, once the model is produced
subsequent analysis is typically,
fairly efficient.